je sais que les prénoms ne vendent pas à
changer leur couleur mais peut-être
qu'il aura un peu plus de chansons
s'appelle alors on écrit tel un prénom
français pour une meilleure intégration
en 1997 femme d'origine algérienne
espérait éviter les discriminations dont
pourraient être victimes ses enfants
principalement en matière d'emploi des
craintes confirmées par ce jeune homme
la même année moi je suis allé une fois
cadarache pour demander du boulot me dit
a pas de boulot mais tous les jours il
m'avait dit ce qui rentre alors c'est
parce que je m'appelle mohamed jamal un
constat qui perdure encore aujourd'hui
en 2016
une enquête du ministère du travail au
sein de grandes entreprises françaises
révélait que le taux global de réponses
positives reçues par une candidature
maghrébine était de 9 % contre 20 % pour
les candidatures hexagonal soit 11
points d'écart
alors pour mettre toutes les chances de
leur côté certains vont jusqu'à changer
leur petit nom à l'état civil en 1993
ces jeunes avaient opté pour des prénoms
bien français à tout appel comment
maintenant philippe c'est quoi tendre et
non un travail
le changement de prénom est possible en
france depuis une loi de janvier 1993
d'après l'article 60 toute personne qui
demande à modifier son état civil doit
justifier d'un intérêt légitime la
discrimination en est un en 2006 les
parents de cette fillette n'avait pas
attendu d'être confrontées à des
discriminations pour demander un prénom
français pour leurs enfants
ce que vous souhaitez vous c'est que cet
enfant porte à double non on est bien
d'accord avec un petit irec marois
procès
c'est bien ça une démarche motivée
encore une fois par un souhait
d'intégration la petite on souhaiterait
qu effectivement permettrait meilleure
intégration à la qualité française
la requête recevra un avis favorable du
procureur mais pour ce sociologue
changer de prénom pour mieux s'intégrer
cela était encore une forme de
discrimination
il est certain que le fait de franciser
améliore mécaniquement mécaniquement et
chances d'accès au logement les chances
d'accès à l'emploi aussi alors ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut forcément que
tout le monde le fasse et l'encourager
et trouvé que cette situation est
normale les discriminations ne sont pas
normales selon le ministère de la
justice en 2018 en france plus de 2500
personnes avaient demandé à changer de
prénom ou de nous le ministère ne
communique pas en revanche sur le nombre
de demandes pour franciser son prénom ou
son patronyme
mais selon certaines estimations elle
représenterait environ 10 % des demandes
[Musique]